I believe that if people
had some sort of goal in their life
and strived to achieve it,
they would live longer.
I never thought I'd finish a marathon,
but so far I have completed 16 of them,
plus eight ultra-marathons.
But I am most happy about the fact
that running has allowed me
to leave the computer
and start doing something that's fun.
Thanks to running,
I started to overcome my weaknesses
and there were quite a few.
I feel stronger, more confident
and better motivated to work and act.
Running has allowed me
to come out of my shell, enjoy life
and live my life to the fullest.
The biggest benefit
of the running event in Krynica
is the fact that it is open to everybody -
professionals and amateurs.
Anyone can come and try any distance.
Short distances,
especially for young people,
are to encourage them to live healthy
lives and show them the benefits of that.
After completing my first ultra-marathon
I wrote some text, a page long.
My friends encouraged me
to start my own blog.
I called my blog,
Stories Written with my Legs,
which reflect all that happens in a race,
meaning the stories written with my legs.
I had the honour to receive a recognition
for the Running Journalist of the Year.
I believe running forms your character.
You become more determined,
tougher, more punctual.
You start to believe
that anything is possible.
Even after a few failures,
you get up, try again and never give up.
The biggest benefit of participating
in the Erasmus+ programme
is the ability to work
with partners in Europe
and promote together the idea
of being active during our running event.